your proper transplant with the Obamas
you were at the famous lost kind of
white house party I was there it was
scary it was all sad those junk I
remember I I just remember like hanging
out and like first of all every black
person was there jay-z Beyonce died and
with the black heaven I remember at one
point of the night I was like with
Michelle Obama and she was like kind of
sad and she's like I don't know what
we're gonna do I don't know what's gonna
happen and I was like
[Applause]
we'll be fine and she looks at me and
she goes I was talking about the country
got a picture of you here you are
yes in the White House I met the man oh
look that was great sharing laughs you
know remember what you were laughing
about ya know exactly wasn't about the
camera to me
[Laughter]
President Obama at the time was telling
me that I was his second favorite
character in The Wire oh yeah number one
yeah Omar was his favorite laughed out
loud as you can see like
you
[Music]